ça fait deux jours que didier durand n'a
pas fermé l'oeil
il est un tailleur de pierre est un des
rares experts qui a le droit de mettre
le pied à l'intérieur de la cathédrale
sinistrés c'est la première fois de ma
vie quand je suis rentré à l'intérieur
hier matin que j'ai pleuré comme un
enfant
il a aussi été un des tout premiers sur
place le soir de l'incendié qui aura été
de cette extraordinaire chaîne humaine
et pro visé pour sortir et sauver les
reliques les oeuvres d'art bref une
poudre un trésor de notre dame j'étais
le 15e violon de cette chaîne et qui
était dans le calme dans le respect avec
tout ce qui doit être fait ce qu'on a pu
transporter ça sera toujours eu un point
important les deux beffroi ils sont dans
le cadre des arches une capacité
ils ont une capacité à retenir
l'ensemble de l'édifice des arches et
même 48 heures plus tard c'est encore
une course contre la montre ont expliqué
les pompiers de paris qui veillent en
permanence sur des parties instable de
la cathédrale qui menace de s'écrouler
si éventuellement le finir tombe il peut
tomber sur l'extérieur mais si pour moi
l'intérieur il va emmener tout les goûts
mais la séparation il faudra donc des
semaines que pour stabiliser la
structure
mais déjà le gouvernement macro on passe
aux grandes annonces et avec les
architectes de la planète à soumettre
leurs idées pour remplacer la flèche
cette flèche dans la destruction attend
hymne au moulin soir le concours
international permettra de trancher la
question de savoir s'il faut
reconstruire une flèche
s'il faut reconstruire la flèche qui
avait été pensée et construite par
viollet le duc dans les mêmes conditions
à l'identique un concours qui ne fait
pas l'unanimité chez les paris hippiques
c'est au compagnon de france de rebâtir
cette flèche et ils peuvent l'arrêt
bâtir comme viollet-le-duc l'a fait
parce qu'il avait mis tout son coeur et
eux mettront tout leur coeur d'autant
plus que le fameux camp qui trônait tout
au bout de cette flèche a été retrouvé
hier comme par miracle dans les
décombres par le curateur de notre dame
vous avez dû voir la photo du coq que
l'architecte en chef à a
à retrouver c'est vrai que
personnellement c'est moi qui lui ai
fait qu'ils aient fait cette photo il
l'a pris la sortie comme un bébé
on va sauver et pour nous les français
le coq c'est l'emblème c'est l'emblème
de la france et on dit toujours dans
notre petit jargon et
le coq chante quand il a les pieds dans
la merde alors nous avons les pieds
brûlés nous avons les pieds dans la mer
mais on va chanter et je pense qu'on va
renaître de nos cendres ce soir c'est la
france au grand complet qui a rendu
hommage à sa cathédrale on a fait sonner
toutes les cloches des églises du pays à
l'unisson et demain ça sera au tour des
bénévoles et des pompiers d'être à
l'honneur ces gens qui ont déployé des
efforts actuellement extraordinaire le
soir du fait des efforts grâce auquel la
cathédrale notre dame de paris
c'est toujours debout ici tamar alter
escaut radio-canada paris